Speaker 1: There is a very interesting and
disturbing article in Vice that I would
encourage all of you to read about anti-vaxxers
now wanting revenge, political revenge and legal
revenge. And what's extraordinarily disturbing
about this is that it doesn't make any sense and
it's very dangerous. And so I'm not going to
tell you everything that is in this article,
but the article is written by Anna Merlyn. It's
part of Motherboard, which is like the tech
side, I guess we would say a vice. And there's a
particular part that I want to point to here. Now,
the subheading of the article says, Buoyed by
the purported end of a pandemic that continues
to kill thousands. Anti-vaccine activists now
vow to punish their enemies. These people said
one need to go to prison. There's a particular
section of this article that is very scary. Okay.
And it reads, Major anti-vaccine figures are now
seizing their chance to enact what they see as
justice and do a little fundraising and image
burnishing in the process. Besides big trees,
nonspecific legal threats, we have children's
health, defense, the most moneyed and
influential anti-vaccine organization in the
US, led by Robert F Kennedy Jr. C, Ph.D., is
often involved in strange and frequently doomed
litigation. But recently, and with much fanfare,
it launched a new one an antitrust lawsuit against
major news organizations and social media outlets,
which they accused of conspiring to collectively
censor online news about COVID. The defendants
included frequent anti-vaxx targets like the
Washington Post and BBC. The plaintiffs are a
veritable who's who of people making bogus hosts
hosts health claims, including C. Ph.D. itself,
Ty and Charlene Bollinger, who run websites and
still sell products devoted to making bogus claims
about cancer and vaccines. Jim Haft, who founded
right wing news site Gateway Pundit, and Joseph
Mercola, who I've spoken about before, a longtime
figure in the natural health world who's been a
major funder of the anti-vax movement. They now
are going to try to seek the revenge they believe
they're entitled to. Now, it's very important to
understand that the vindication they are asserting
for themselves, they are claiming the anti-vaxx
are claiming they have been vindicated. Now,
often and I know that this is hard to
believe. Often it's as simple as, oh, you
know what? We were right. They said the vaccine
prevented COVID and it doesn't. Boom. Okay,
Now, only if you do no investigation yourself
and completely suspend all memory of what took
place for years. Could you believe that in
the real world we have a more evidence based?
Understand? Ending not only of vaccines but of
COVID and all of these different things. And so,
for example, when you take the claim they told
us the vaccine prevented COVID and it doesn't.
You have to remember three plus years. Has it been
three? Yeah, more than three years of history. The
original vaccine meant to focus in on the original
variant was very good at preventing transmission
and infection. Meaning with that original vaccine,
you were actually very protected against getting
COVID at all. As the virus continued to mutate.
The effectiveness of the vaccine against infection
diminished. This wasn't hidden. There was no cover
up. It was all over the news as soon as it became
known. And over time, the vaccine became less
effective, down to most recently from the latest
studies I've seen. Essentially not effective
at all at preventing infection or transmission.
The vaccine became primarily a tool that will
prevent you from getting sick and prevent you
from dying, but with relatively good efficacy,
arguably saving millions, if not more lives.
That doesn't vindicate the anti-vax people. The
anti-vax people were saying the same thing all
along. What changed are the circumstances of the
virus and the vaccines. Similarly, they claim to
be vindicated over side effects, myocarditis,
pericarditis, except they'll never tell you the
real data about the risks of those conditions from
the vaccine versus the risks of those conditions
from COVID. That's something they conveniently
leave out. They insist that there were cover
ups about hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin
and zinc and vitamin C and vitamin D and all
these different things. And they say they won't
even allow it to be studied. But you can look up
and find endless peer reviewed studies about all
elements of that. It seems as though maintaining
a good level of vitamin D, generally speaking, is
a good thing for fighting off a lot of infections,
and that includes COVID, that includes COVID, the
zinc zip back. Vitamin C thing does not appear to
be useful. Ivermectin and hydroxychloroquine
have now been studied very much extensively,
not effective on COVID. So the vindication they
claim, one could only believe if you either
aren't paying attention or aren't actually
looking for scientific peer reviewed data.
But that doesn't mean they aren't going to ruin
a lot of people's lives with these lawsuits and
these calls for retribution. So read the vice
article. We'll link to it in the description to
the YouTube video for this story, and we'll talk
more about it as those lawsuits move forward.